A man would be strategic. A woman would be manipulative.
A man, a man would be a leader.
A woman would be controlling.
A man would be authoritative.
A woman would be annoying.
A man would be called confident,
but a woman would be called arrogant.
A man would be on compromising.
A woman would be a ball breaker.
A man would be assertive. A woman would be aggressive.
The behaviour is the same.
What is different is the body exhibiting that behaviour.
And so
I began to see that when people judge a woman for being aggressive
or ambitious or annoying,
it really wasn't qualities of ambition or aggression
that they were judging. It was actually women that were being judged.
So we should change laws that diminish women,
but changing mindsets is even more important.
We should enact policies that support women.